he went how are you I'm good how are you
I'm doing so great thanks for doing this
by the way I know this is like very odd
to these zoom things but I kind of love
it
so listen scoring a ticket to Hamilton
was so hard and I know you guys did
everything you could from coming out to
the streets to perform and now there's
multiple companies around the world but
what a fabulous thing that everyone will
have the chance to see the show what
does that mean to you it means
everything because obviously
accessibility was so important to us
from those live ham for ham shows to the
whole front row being 10 to front two
rows being tech bucks and still and
still you know when you get a relative
that calls you being like I can't
believe it's $5,000 I know no we're not
charging $5,000 someone else is buying
our tickets and charging $5,000 so I
mean that was really one of the reasons
we wanted to film this we wanted to
capture this moment in time capture this
incredible company and and we did it
ourselves we filmed it on a we filmed
two performances on a Sunday and a
Tuesday and then filmed close-up Sunday
night all day Monday on our day off from
the show and Tuesday morning and it is
not easy to plan a film shoot while you
are also performing eight shows a week
but this is the fruits of our labor is
that now the world gets to see Hamilton
with that company at that moment almost
five years ago to the day and we have it
I'm really glad we got it
[Music]
[Music]
I actually love I know this was supposed
to be theaters and this was supposed to
be in a different way for you but I
actually love with what's going on in
the world right now the fact that what
Hamilton stands for the story of America
been told by America now and where we
are at in our culture and this
revolution it just feels so great to
have a show like yours available for
everyone I know I'm really grateful that
in a time when there is no live theater
we are this giant love-letter to live
theater and what it feels like to be in
a room with a bunch of strangers sharing
musical I'm really grateful that we're
able to provide that in a big way at a
time when you know we don't the future
looks is hazy the eight-balls coming up
with nothing when it comes to live
theater all over the world and to at
this sort of you know the thing about
Hamilton is because it brushes up
against the founding of this country it
yes it hits different depending on where
we are as a country there are lines
about slavery there are lines about how
little the founders did that hit
different now than they did in 2016 that
they did under Obama versus under Trump
because my only real insight in writing
the show was all of the problems and
paradoxes and fights at the fat present
at the founding are still here they're
all still here that's how I was able to
write about them because I was pulling
for contemporary language over the same
fights
and that's includes the original sin of
slavery that includes systemic racism
that includes gun controls on accident
that every character in our show dies as
a result of gun violence that's still a
plague on our country and so you know it
just because it deals with issues at the
root like it's always going to be
relevant in some form and some things
differently than others and while we
live in a country where black people are
under attack from embolden white
supremacy police brutality and centuries
of systemic anti black racism it's up to
us in words and deeds to stand up for
our fellow citizens here's the silver
lining of theatres being dark we have a
chance to address a ton of systemic
issues that don't necessarily get
addressed when you're just worrying
about getting your eight shows done a
week and we're building five companies
as fast as we can so as many people have
access to Hamilton as possible we have a
chance to slow down we have a chance to
talk to our company members and say you
know what are our backstage is not as
diverse as our onstage and we need to
fix that we need to address that our
audience is not as diverse as our cast
and you need to find ways to fix that
and we need to address that so so much
of that moment is not just about
speaking up that in arguable truth that
black lives matter but also let's take
this moment to commit ourselves to real
change that when we return to the
theatre we're returning to a more
equitable and just and fair theatre for
all of us Bravo was ready to make steel
borrow a bar then a hurricane came and
devastation rained our man saw his
future drip drip and down the drain some
good news you were on some good news and
it was fabulous what was it like getting
everyone together and did you have any
times where you maybe didn't remember
the lines do it in your sleep I've had
times when I don't remember my
choreography I didn't write our
choreography but um but know what was
glorious about doing some good news as
one john is just he just asks the
impossible because he doesn't even know
it's impossible he goes can you all get
together and you know we had not been
together as an original cast
in ages I mean really in five years and
this is even before I think this is even
before we moved up the release and so
he's just ask the impossible because
it's John and his heart is pure you just
say yeah we'll figure out how to do it
and we called everyone and everyone
who's game and the joy of just even
doing this press is like we still are
feeding off the good energy of that
mitzvah of doing that good work for for
John show Little Mermaid we're so
excited in the heights we're so excited
any surprises there are new songs for
the Little Mermaid Holly Bailey is gonna
be such an incredible Ariel getting to
write music for these characters that
are probably the reason I started
writing musicals in the first place it
was actually easier than I thought
the hardest part was my own intimidation
in working with Alan Menken and that was
entirely self-imposed but when it came
to how these characters speak and what
they say I'm I've known that a little so
that was a joy and then I mix you know
the timeline worked out the way it did
for whatever reason it did but I am so
excited that you're gonna see Anthony
Ramos first in Hamilton
then you're gonna seem to be a big ol
movie star and then the heights
next summer hopefully in a theater where
we can share popcorn and macho's and
wave berto Rican and Dominican flags in
there
[Music]